what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
you know the one thing I hate the most
about having the flu is my schedule gets
all thrown off and so it's like okay
like I am in no condition to record
so whatever videos we have online those
videos are going out and only in care if
it matches the schedule or not like it's
it's it's crazy like it is it is rough
but we are finally back on track we're
finally back on our schedule we're doing
our Green Lantern's on Sundays and again
we're picking up with the green lantern
line of stories as part of brightest day
and I'm actually I mean I'll be honest
here guys I actually like Green Lantern
more than I like the main brightest day
story now a lot of that again is because
of the fact that brightest day was
designed to detail the 12 heroes 12
villains or what have you they came back
to life after the events of blackest
night but if those are characters that
you were never really interested in in
the first place the main story probably
wouldn't intrigue you that much and so
again because the fact that that Green
Lantern focuses on the Lantern entities
this is where all the world-building yes
and I remember we've basically fleshed
out a couple things the first is that
parallax the yellow lantern entity the
agency of the Sinestro Corps the being
that possessed Hal Jordan during the
events of Emerald Twilight that was only
the first entity that we knew of and
there were so many others to go over
there was also the entity of the orange
lantern that was basically that was
essentially possessed by Hector Hammond
who is one of the most notable enemies
of Hal Jordan now at the point right now
Hector Hammond is still out there he's
not been captured off panel or anything
like that in terms of like how Jordan
and those guys he's just still floating
around out there and that's gonna be
kind of a focal point of this story to a
degree especially when it comes to the
character of of Larfleeze but at this
moment what we actually end up doing
here is picking up with a prison in
Montana this effectively just kind of
been totally obliterated and destroyed
and the way is described here is that
there was something that was akin to a
bull that just kind of ran through this
whole thing and tore everything out that
basically - sort of riveting the prison
to pieces and all that kind of good
stuff and where the cops are kind of
trying to figure out what's going on and
where they're analyzing the situation
and they're talking about how to take it
out what is up happening as one of them
describes it as a being that's made of
like fire or something along those lines
and then Atrocitus shows up alongside
Sinestro and says that's because it's
not fire it's pure rage now remember
after the events of blackest night well
we kind of had where all these leaders
of the Lantern course who showed up on
earth to fight Necron the leader of the
black Lantern's and following necrons
defeat we basically had the white
lantern that showed up and because the
white Lantern was there what it meant is
that everybody was kind of curious about
it
same time you had the white lantern that
was essentially like issuing orders like
Hal Jordan and Sinestro and Carroll
fares are the star sapphires and
essentially saying you have to find the
entities I so it was kind of a way to
keep the various leaders of the Lantern
course confined to earth to kind of keep
them there
while some may have stray they
ultimately came back and it was designed
to basically bring them all together for
a singular cause and that's really where
this was you know that was really the
basis behind this its fleshing out all
these entities these beings that are
kind of like a representation of the
emotional spectrum I remember they're
not the sum total of the emotional
spectrum like the bull is not the sum
total of all energy of rage it's just
the representation of Rage is kind of
one of those interesting metaphysical
things but it does serve its purpose
because one of the things that happens
here is the character of Atrocitus and
this was not necessarily designed to be
a kind of rework of his character well
just to say it wasn't really like
turning the character of Atrocitus into
a hero what it was designed to do in a
lot of ways
what's fleshes character out now the
reason I say that is remember when
Atrocitus first showed up in the green
lantern line of comics he was just a
raging monster in a lot of different
ways and the reason why was because his
people had been totally obliterated by
the Manhunters the robots designed by
the guardians of the universe ah who
were ultimately decommissioned and
replaced with the Green Lantern's to
police the universe but because of that
Atrocitus has always had a hatred for
the guardians of the universe themselves
but he was almost always driven by like
rage and anger but ever since he learned
of the bull basically the entity that
represents rage in the emotional
spectrum
he's been constantly seeking after it
and whether it's because of this sort of
focal point which is to say he can kind
of channel all of his energies and all
of his thoughts into finding this one
thing or if it's because he's been
working alongside Hal Jordan and he's
worked alongside Sinestro and he's got
other Lantern Corps members that he's
been working with for whatever reason
he's experiencing a kind of shift of
source in a sense that there's basically
this bus full of uh of prisoners and he
effectively kills them all he
annihilates them all in their entirety
and when the question is asked by
Sinestro why would you do this
Atrocitus response is because those who
would take life don't deserve it you
know they did they basically deserve to
lose there's individuals who would bring
harm or bring pain and suffering to
innocent people don't deserve to live
now this is kind of funny because this
does fit into Atrocitus is not like you
know geoff johns took a huge paradigm
shift
Atrocitus is motivation while it was
predicated on the loss of his family and
his desire is to take out the Guardians
and the Green Lantern's
it's not just a desire to kill but for
the most part he believes he'll he'll
bring peace to the universe that if he
eliminates the guardians of the universe
if he eliminates the Green Lantern's
these kind of agents for the guardians
schemes and motivations with what really
with Atrocitus knowing a lot of the
things that the Green Lantern's don't in
his mind he's basically allowing people
to live their own lives outside of the
invisible and oftentimes subtle control
of the Guardians themselves so he's not
really a villain now his actions in
terms of attacking Green Lantern's and
killing them things like that that could
be construed as being villainous
depending on how you view the Green
Lantern's and that's something I want
you guys to keep in mind because as we
progress throughout Geoff Johns run what
we're gonna do is we're gonna start to
make this shift this kind of transition
between the Green Lantern's being just
holy good guys to where we start to look
at the Green Lantern's with a bit of a
skewed eye and especially the guardians
of the universe works like are they
really the heroes that we always thought
they were but at this point we switch
back to Zam Ron I remember in the last
video we had talked about how the entity
that represents these star sapphires is
the predator and because all these
entities were on earth and because all
these entities they kind of just escaped
or at least people became aware of their
presence following the arrival of the
white lantern
what we basically had as kind of this
gold rush for the respective Lantern
cores to track down their entities and
Carol Ferris had effectively come across
the predator and then in turn brought
the predator back to xamarin but the
idea was that the central power battery
kind of ran on the predator more or less
when the predator had effectively left
when that energy had escaped and the
predator had arrived on earth the belief
of the star sapphires was well it's only
a matter of time before we use up all
the energy in the central power battery
but this is what Carol Ferris came along
and said that's not true like every
other Lantern core that exists out there
the central power battery the central
point by which you guys as star
sapphires derive your power that's all
based on the emotional aspect of love
and so long as there is love in the
universe there will always be energy in
the star sapphire central power battery
and so at that point the question became
what do we do with the predator in the
dying moments of the former Queen Queen
agapo of the star sapphires she had
basically made Carol Ferris the new
queen and so what this means is that
Carol Ferris now leaves the star
sapphire but the idea here is that again
what seems to be hinting at here is that
if Carol Ferris may very well bond with
the entity itself that were not a
hundred percent sure about I mean at
this point we're not really given an
answer instead you know she just kind of
takes off with the entity and when
Howerton says when you gonna be back she
says
when the job is done which of course is
the same answer that house worden always
gave Carol whenever he took off but at
this point we switch over to Michigan
and we basically pick up with a young
girl and who had effectively just gone
missing it's basically the idea that
Nicole had been taken captive by some
guy but it's interesting because this
girl basically says I forgive you for
the things that you've done and you know
I hope that you forgive me for what I'm
about to do but I've always been told
you have to forgive those that do wrong
and that's what's so cool about this is
because she immediately topples this guy
you know me you know throws soup at
Amanda no to essentially tries to make
her escape and subdue him but then she
suddenly met by the arrival of adhara
the Blue Lantern entity and this is cool
because the way this girl talked when
she said I forgive you for the things
that you've done you know it's very much
Blue Lantern like because it's really
more about like inner peace because it's
really more about finding a kind of
place within yourself where you find a
measure of contentment and you find hope
that's exactly what Nicole's found and
of course she ends up becoming a
becoming a host for a Dora the Blue
Lantern entity now at this point we
switch back over to Larfleeze and this
is why I say this is where the story
kind of begins to emphasize the nature
of Larfleeze with regards to Hector
Hammond remember when it comes to the
various Lantern cores that are out there
they have a central power battery and a
central power battery is is exactly what
it sounds like it's a giant you know
Lantern more or less in the color of
whatever core represents but the idea is
that is kind of like a consolidation
factory all the emotion that belongs to
that one particular Lantern Court is
kind of consolidated inside the central
power battery is sort of funneled into
that battery itself or at least a
battery draws on that part of the
emotional spectrum and from there all
that energy is just divvied out among
the various lanterns that exists out
there but remember the amount of energy
any one Lantern Hin use is essentially
based on how many lanterns are out there
so while there is a lot of energy that's
there one of the things that was
established when it came to blarf Lee's
the orange lantern is that with the
green lanterns you have like 3600
lanterns that are out there and so you
have all this energy split among 3600
people what happens when you have that
all that energy that goes into one
person that's how it works with
Larfleeze Larfleeze is the orange
lantern the orange lantern of greed of
avarice and so instead of having like a
huge central power battery that anybody
can locate anybody can tap into instead
it's just his little battery that he
keeps confined to himself and that'll
fit ian the orange lantern entity was
confined in now of course with Hector
Hammond consuming
that lantern all that energy is now in
him and what it means is the power of
Larfleeze is slowly starting to drain
and this is pretty significant because
as a lantern based on greed he wants as
much as he can possibly have he's
literally just a hoarder and so because
of that when his plant when his Lantern
power starts to dissipate it's crushing
because now his self-identity begins to
go away now in truth if the orange
lantern was removed from Larfleeze for
any real measure of time let's say for
like a few weeks or a few months he
would revert back to his normal state he
would no longer be governed by like
greed or anything along those lines or
at least that's that's how I would
interpret I wouldn't think that would be
the case but regardless of the scenario
with his power effectively waning he's
been tasked with kind of keeping an eye
on a guy named Abraham who is basically
the host for the UH deter entity when it
first popped up on earth before Carol
Ferris took a to uh to xamarin and it is
kind of cool here because what we end up
finding out is that one mark flees is
not the actual name of this guy and to
his family still alive and they still
miss him to a degree now Larfleeze has
for the most part casts off his former
identity he's basically just become the
person he is now and almost doesn't want
to go back to the person that he was
before but it is kind of cool because
when he goes to attack Abraham of course
how Jordan shows up and how jordan says
look we can't have this you need to calm
down he's chill we're here to protect
this guy for you know whatever reason
whatever the motivation is but in the
middle of this conflict they're having
their suddenly met by the arrival of
Saint Walker or at least by a message
from Saint Walker now the funny thing
about this if st. Walker basically grabs
them and says adhara has arrived
adhara has chosen a host now remember
when it comes to a person becoming a
blue lantern that's not something that's
just readily done it's a huge like trial
like you're put through all these trials
and all these tribulations and they
hardcore test your mettle that's why you
don't have 3600 blue lanterns running
around and most you have like five but
the fact that adhara has chosen a host
is very interesting because adhara is
kind of designed to be this sort of
harbinger for how it is the blue
lanterns choose and so if a door is
chosen a host it means a door has
essentially searched throughout all
however many billions of people on earth
and settled on one person the person
best suited to instill hope in others of
course that person being a cult and so
it's awesome because for the blue
lanterns is a time of celebration it's
time to kind of look around and say this
is what we've been striving for all this
time is to find a dark and then in turn
see if we can't find a way to use that
energy to bolster the power of the blue
lanterns or the very least to find a way
to consolidate
that energy into ourselves it is kind of
cool because in this moment a door
begins to sort of analyze the various
people who were here she analyzes
Larfleeze for example it says your
parents are still alive and your parents
still miss you why do you choose to live
this life of a you know auras Lantern
where you're so full of like a void a
void that can never truly be filled if
you let this go and you go back to your
family you'll find the life that you've
been searching for with Hal Jordan it's
a lot more interesting
you know the idea is that she analyzes
Hal Jordan and says you are filled with
hope but for whatever reason you won't
allow yourself to feel it like you won't
allow yourself to be full of hope you're
afraid of hope why are you afraid of
hope now if I'm gonna be honest with you
guys I would look at Hal Jordan I would
say he's afraid of Hope because of what
could happen how at one point was what
hopeful he was a guy who was full of
hope full of beautiful tomorrows and
Leah who knows what'll happen and who
knows what the future will bring but
it'll definitely be brighter than today
and then like Coast City was destroyed
and then he was possessed by the
parallax entity and then he wiped out
all the green lancers and killed all the
guardians of the universe except one and
then he waged war against the entirety
of the DC Universe crushed Superman
defeated all the superheroes and tried
to blink reality out of existence and
him being possessed by parallax is
predicated on the idea that he lost what
he loved he lost hope basically and so
if he goes back to being hopeful the
larlie enough to care about things again
he makes himself pray for parallax and
this is kind of interesting because
while we end up having you know Adar who
looks to be like converting house we ran
into a blue lantern suddenly the two of
them are severed the two of them are
separated and the reason why is because
they're met by the arrival of the flash
and the flash simply says we have to
talk about the friends that you're
spending time with we have to talk about
the people that you're keeping company
with and we have to talk about that
right now but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here - comments explained
make sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the robb quark you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]